as we have a very special guest with
Maurice Jennifer yes we have a
compelling Rimi and she is with Maurice
Ashley to talk about her support of the
scene Lewis campus yes
dr. Aiken Pellegrini is that correct
correct yes director of a business
administration and executive education
at the University of Missouri I'm sure a
lot of Mizzou fans are jumping up and
down well I'm at the University of
Missouri st. Louis ok you tell us about
what your work is there so at the
college of business administration we
have a doctor of Business Administration
program for working professionals I'm
the director of that DBA program I also
oversee our executive continuing
business education programs and
corporate trainings now we know that you
guys sponsor the strategy across the
board gala that we had first thank you
for that what is the connection between
chess and what you do at the University
well I became familiar with the San Luis
chess club through a friend of mine TIA
who's been a longtime supporter of the
club and so I became familiar with all
the initiatives and all the community
trainings that you provide and I was
really impressed the first time I was
here was with actually with a few years
ago with Girl Scouts and so I came here
and I was just so impressed with you
know with the involvement the caring the
passion that the instructors had so so I
was really impressed with what I saw and
with the launch of the DBA program I
just really wanted to support all the
initiatives especially because
especially the community trainings that
you provide align really well with our
own mission to transform lives through
education that was the next question I
was going to ask you how does chess
connect with a program like yours is
there a direct connection so there is I
would say the the chess as well as the
DBA training they're just really they
provide they align well with each other
so for example the DBA trainings
PBA is the highest academic credential
in business education so typically our
students are executives but we do have
students who are mid-level managers who
are emerging leaders and the goal of the
training is to really marry rigor and
relevance in research so the the
students are trained in conducting
rigorous research with the objective of
applying the findings to real-world
decision-making in industry so in that
sense I mean it's actually is because I
think the chess as well as the DBA
training have a unique ability to
provide challenging intellectual
self-improvement and and so they're very
similar in that sense and also chess is
a game of strategy and strategic
decision-making is something that our
executive students tackle on a daily
basis and so I think chess and and also
DBA training provides certain skills
there are very similar such as a new way
of thinking perseverance and definitely
mental agility oh we are you teaching
chess in this program as well are they
getting chest training they are not
there over there we have a lot of people
in business and chess right I mean the
program is a supporter of the San Luis
chess club but through the program we've
had several executive students who
started who have started supporting the
club as well so yeah I mean that could
be the next step I've gotta get the gyms
over there sure somebody like yeah
sister Juana
he's a big mogul multi-billionaires what
I hear but definitely that would be a
great connection what's next for your
program in chess what's next for our
program and chess so the TBA we are a
new program we are the only AACSB with
only and the first ast SP are created
TBI program in the region offering
research in all areas of Business
Administration and we're just so proud
that we've been consistently ranked as a
top team in the world actually just last
week we got the new stat CEO magazine
ranked us in the top 26 in the world and
thank you and top 16 in the country
so we have students commuting to st.
Louis one weekend a month from 12
different states so we attract students
from all over and so what's next for the
DBA and for chess is that we will
continue to grow we will continue to
maintain our accreditation and
recognition is a top global DBA program
and we will continue to bring executives
to the region for our DBA program and as
we grow we will also support st. Louis
chess club in its growth initiatives as
well speaking of growth you know we
think that may be double the funding
maybe this year or next there's a little
suggestion of course we're sure we want
to support the program okay you see my
sales skills by the way Laureen if
you're listening you might want to hire
I'll take it executive students you know
with with 17,000 students we are the
largest public research university in
the region in in eastern Missouri and
and very similar to what this club does
with related to its impact in the region
we also on a daily basis transform lives
through education we really want to
support this club because it just aligns
so well with the mission of the
university as well as the DBA program so
maybe I should have asked for triple or
better dr. Aiken Pellegrini Director of
Business Administration or dr. business
administration and of the executive
education program we really appreciate
all that you do contributing to chess
and thank you for all that you do